so as we see this all happening let's
talk about China here is a man who's the
president United States who came in and
he had to put it lightly some very
radical ideas compared to the
establishment this is everything from
the D globalization this is taking on
China directly in all the trade will
call it talks if you want befriending
dictators of enemies of the United
States and kind of playing up those
relationships to questioning very
long-term relationships that the United
States has both on the diplomatic side
but also things like the world World
Health Organization the climate Accord
all these different things whenever
there is something very disruptive like
that it's obviously gonna be polarizing
so I don't want to get into kind of the
political polarization that's
well-documented but the one thing that
in some weird world we've backed into
many of those policies are now going to
be adopted but the impetus for them is
not going to be our president wants to
do this it's going to be the virus
forced us to do this right so the D
globalization now everyone wants to take
on China both sides of the aisle are
looking over there and saying whoa hold
on a second right and it may be for some
different reasons but ultimately we get
this showdown and so you know you know I
spent a year in Iraq a war that was
started over WMDs that weren't there and
there's a lot of people I think that a
question that whole narrative of what
you know 18 20 years later why are we
still at war in the Middle East this is
not a let's go invade you know the the
largest population country in the world
this is let's engage in an economic war
that 50-plus percent of our country
doesn't even understand right and so
let's just start at a high level how you
see us position
today like that economic battlefield if
you will like how is it positioned and
then where do we go yeah the lots of
unpack on China Trump ran for president
on make America great again and like you
said again back to this the great
accelerator he was already making moves
on China way before anybody ever said
coronavirus
and you had the tera fours which were
you know a year ago alright that those
cranked up and they came to this like
pseudo deal that you knew that like the
pseudo deal was really just Chum was
like that's enough for my first term and
like I'm definitely coming back to these
guys in the second term and a lot of
this has been driven for Trump honest
has been driven by Steve Antin right
that is the most hawkish guy that's
closest to Trump and Steve Bannon was
out here the whole time with Kyle bass
and some of these other guys with the
level of hawkish nests it felt like it
was kind of halfway to Alex Jones right
especially it felt unpresidential in a
way because Obama was such a you know he
really was a globalist and he wanted
everybody to get along as a big get
along guy right and that felt the Obama
is incredibly presidential right it's
just I mean sometimes politics aside
sometimes I see Trump get on TV and you
really miss Oklahoma right regardless of
policy decisions but just like you know
Obama's a good guy right so so with the
so with the globalization Trump starts
wanting to walk that back and here comes
coronavirus I'm of the opinion that
you know it's it's becoming increasingly
apparent that the United States is gonna
hold China accountable for coronavirus
and there's gonna be a full uncovering
of the facts I have no doubt that the
intelligence agencies like let's be like
how how much digging do you think the
intelligence agencies have been doing
over the last couple months let's be
honest let's just frame it like that and
we don't have to answer the question
just sprang the question they're going
to answer for that and then you're just
starting to see the first things trickle
in right like what you said World Health
Organization okay a number of other
things and then here comes a supply
chain coming back and the craziest thing
the experience for me personally that's
been crazy is that if you listen to
Steve band's podcast at all so I haven't
listened to Steve banning before you
tell us about this podcast the one thing
I will say about Steve and Kyle so I did
an episode with Kyle I went down to
Texas and had launched and it was
fantastic incredibly intelligent guy
right obviously I left and I said he
really believes what he's saying right
that there was there's no doubt there
was no kind of anything I didn't know
anything about Steve Bannon before I
went down there we did not talk about
Steve man and while I was there
afterwards
I saw on real vision that Kyle
interviewed Steve band I watched that
episode and basically you could sum up
my understanding of Steve Bannon as
headline you know kind of coverage of
him right so kind of he was the the
right-wing crazy guy that the media
really caught took some shots at and
that was you know that's all I knew
about him didn't know anything after I
listened to him and Kyle talked in that
interview I said two things you can't
argue with this Steve Bannon is
incredibly intelligent Marv and Steve
Bannon
has a better pulse on the geopolitical
landscape then pretty much almost
anybody else I've heard talk about yeah
right yeah and he may be wrong he may be
right he may be you know ill-advised in
one area he may be kind of you know
waving his hand in other areas whatever
but the dude is on top of a lot of stuff
and so I have not listened to the
podcast but I just want to put that out
there as I was very surprised when I
heard him talking on those two fronts
yeah so so the way the way that my china
view has been formed really over the
last probably five weeks or so at the
beginning of April I started listening
to Steve band's podcast the guy goes 2
hours a day like 6 days that we played a
lot of content man and again it's like
kind of halfway to Alex Jones but I
started noticing that he was talking
about things that were that the United
States was going to do on the podcast
and then like 10 days later it would
come true like Trump would do it and you
already see some announcement you'd see
some move and he had talked about he
took he called the pulling pulling the
funding from the World Health
Organization he called that a month
before it happened and he was talking
about it factually and
and so that was the first thing and then
I think in the second week of April
I saw Bill Maher say that we need to
call this the China virus and that
there's not
we shouldn't be changing the
nomenclature whatever of how viruses are
named just to try and be not step on
anybody's toes in China okay this is not
Kyle bass saying this this is deeply
left right the champion of tomorrow
right and then I started thinking about
it and you you start this is what I'm in
at the beginning of this conversation
where you see how all these things
interconnected and you start thinking
about the inflation thing and then you
start thinking about how the hell we're
going to get we need jobs
we really really need jobs and then you
start thinking about the potential for
behind closed doors politicians on a
conservative side rapidly arriving at
the view that you know the CCP the
Chinese Communist Party is is being
treated as you know really a bad actor
and we're treating them them as a bad
actor because there's now this body of
evidence that shows that they're acting
as a bad actor towards us and it's not
kinetic war which was what we used to
call war like what you want to go do and
but now I'm talking about the economic
war and the information war and you're
increasingly seeing this this mounting
body of evidence that that is what's
going on and one of the main ways that I
realized that it was going to get
bipartisan support
after you think about inflation which
you need and the job creation which you
need
was one of the main reasons that that
progressives were having a hard time
getting on the this make America great
anti chip is because it feels xenophobic
right building a wall along the Mexico
Texas border feels very xenophobic and
progressives have definitely tried to
paint some of the situation's going on
with China in a in a xenophobic type of
manner and I understand that well what
you're able to do is this is not about
the Chinese people we love the Chinese
people this is not about Chinese
Americans we love Chinese Americans this
is about the Chinese Communist Party
we're fighting communism and there is
nothing more that Americans love than to
fight communism and when you can reframe
it like that is we actually want to free
the Chinese people from the communist
rule and then you start getting these
USSR look-alikes and that picture yeah
what what Democrats gonna what how do
you stand up to that
oh no I'm super super Pro China cuz I
don't like jobs for Americans in the
worst economic downturn in American
history when J unemployment rate is it
unprecedented levels oh no I don't want
to bring jobs back to America nobody's
gonna take that stance and now it
doesn't have to be about xenophobia and
again I'm not this is not my view this
is my observation of these pieces that
have been laying in place and the amount
of you know it was a little over a month
ago that I think got a kind of canvas
realization and the amount of dominoes
that have started falling and this broad
direction is giving me pretty strong
confidence that the United States is
about to put the screws to China a bunch
of different ways and to a degree that I
think just a really short amount of time
ago would have thought is being
impossible and then
we're gonna see how strong the Chinese
economy really is like when the United
States really tries to start to to punch
back I think in you know against a lot
of the different things that been going
on